that is terrifying oh my God
this is wild this is so sick
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am joined once again
by the one and only Tara Erickson one and only
we're gonna win Tara what are we watching today
called missing missing
top-notch comedy today I tried you have seen
the first installment searching years ago you
don't really remember I don't remember any
of it except that he was very good I have
not seen the movie searching well um opposite
sides of the grass yeah that's how the phrase
goes I was like well let's watch this one it's
currently number one on Netflix I haven't even
seen the trailer for this have you no I was
like what is that like with repulsive yes I
did oh trailers seriously I don't know what this
is he was like missing I was like who where are
they why and who is it is it a friend a family
member do we like them or not like them I would
love to know let's find out who's missing
in this I think we're in the right energy
mindset for it so ladies and gentlemen leave
that like and just for Tara's beautiful vocals
[Music]
with your own copy of missing available
for super sexy rejects thank you all who
have joined our patreon page for all
these movie reactions alone your hair
fixing sound effects are happening right into
the microphone that was my bad you say you're
lying again I don't do retakes here if bear
gets in here person next to me look bad I'm
not doing a retake okay if it just makes me
solely look bad retakes all day then I look
bad and you know I don't mind it all right
guys let's ruin this movie for all of you
what's that James [Music] are you okay
uh what it's a story of grief as well oh sad oh
shoot you trying to delete them okay keep it happy
but you two are gonna get through this I'm here
for you someday she'll understand that's sad man
development this morning as a green Toyota
cam wait is this like a found footage movie
or is it a splice I don't know I'll find out
why am I asking questions shut up [Laughter]
they're watching Netflix [Music]
this is a very fascinating POV Siri please time
listen I am running late and I need you to write
a couple of things down no alcohol do not open
the door for strangers and keep your location
I left a key with Heather just call her again
so you pick Heather of all people you do not
understand the sacrifices I made to get you mommy
you were telling me that um okay oh what's she
what's she doing what's she doing apple juice
who spends that much money on Apple Juice I
love your mom I know I planned this for just me
and her but it's for a very special reason ah
oh yeah I need you to pick us up on Monday
at LAX can you do that Monday is terrible
that's when you say no Mom that's the
real horror movie right that's true
nothing intense has happened and I'm getting so
much anxiety it's from all those windows open on
her desk it really doesn't feel that way this is
like over stimulation of apps everywhere would
you be able to relent wait you're gone but you
can't just try to enjoy oh oh so it's Father's Day
say it oh cruel cold you're cold-hearted girl
dang okay that's a party right there
in the trunk trunk party where's the
apple juice exactly it's missing
the apple juice is What's missing
be right there
she's here hey Junie damn what
a fascinating style you know I
could stay and hang if you're bored oh no it's
okay I'm just looking forward to a quiet night
is this what searching style is like this
is soap creative don't remember because I
like how it's still very cinematic this is
amazing like editing yeah like what [Music]
yeah wow holy crap
how do you put in the words this style it's
just all from I mean brand new is the words
brand new style Greg it's just like one of a
kind screen screen found screen footage yeah
oh cut her off right at the side there dang
oh [__] is it the model who goes missing
God we thought it was her the entire time
oh snap in Colombia that is not good oh man
then junebug's gonna become an action hero
yep kill the down two parents strong woman
arises hi this is Grace Allen please leave
a message where are you guys I've been
standing here forever let me know when
you get this what if this is just one giant
lesson the mom's trying to teach her cruel
[Music]
um
what do you mean look for the Popsicles exactly
wait what oh [__] [Music] I don't know
oh my God that is so scary
dog they're gonna say no it'll work
wow this is nerve-wracking you gotta call Heather
and be like Heather you got lawyer money we got to
go to Columbia that's what you got to do girl
she just won that lawsuit and don't forget to
buy apple juice yeah I'll make some more calls
somebody's got to be open 24 7. so I'll just
fill out this form and don't worry I'm gonna come
by first thing tomorrow morning when the embassy
opens okay maybe he proposed she said yes and then
went and took a trip like yeah Extended Stay she
threw her phone into the ocean yes the Romantic
gesture we're here at the moment totally and you
use evidence from a concert you have
legal access to otherwise nothing we
learn will be admissible in court hold on
I think I might have something God this
is like [__] this feels so real oh
my God despite its really wicked Style
maybe it's her name her name weird Junebug yeah
there we go bug oh [__]
[Applause]
oh my God no
is this real uh yeah I got some
people I want to check in on I
don't think you'll be able to make them out Gray
oh oh can you do that in Colombia
Go Ninja translate to English Bobo
Dan this is a clever ass screenplay gosh
this is so good Elite wow all right all
right here we go 48 an hour you gotta call
the lawyer I'm not worth it man oh my God
just call the lawyer the loidy I
far from here I don't understand trying to find
uh please it's my mom you make me think of my son
never take enough for an answer Javier was the
right call I can't get into her accounts even
if I wanted to you said she's traveling with her
boyfriend so if you can't find hers maybe I can
find him yeah to recover your just have to verify
a couple things starting with with birth November
10th 1980. great her mother's made Chen Julia
Chen and then the name of your Elementary School
damn you've searched fast
but Elementary
they work yeah
okay uh there's no like need to approve on his
phone or anything like that huh yeah that's
weird maybe enough service wait he was texting me
the whole time unless he turned off his location
or someone else did the footage is already gone
oh two American tourists live on Friday so they're
going to leave and your mother says sorry because
she spilled some wine on the bed sheets and this
is like one in the afternoon okay no start over
the shovels and and hammers oh of cemetery oh
he wants to go grave Robbie
they're so kidnapped that's not the store that's
that's where you go to pay too much for the drinks
ah the workers see if they saw anything okay oh
yeah just buy some gum to see if the bank code
matches do this Javier guy is great he's got to
move up from two stars to five immediately yeah
I hope she gives a really honest review and stuff
it gets like terrible feedback he helped me find
my mom are you coming over I'm sorry I gotta go
into the office I had to change a client meeting
but I'll be there what what who's it what no
matching six months to go wait wait hold up
I think Kevin was cheating cheating
what is this he clearly has a type
oh my God okay let's get to it
get to it who are these people
what the hell wait who's Greg I'm great
oh it's him he's like this woman
calls him Darren holy [__]
human trafficking slash murder
one result ah is he just like
yeah and fraud registered to whoa there are people
who really pull [__] like this man that is crazy
[Music]
it's just a Twist and tourney movie man oh my
God keep in mind that all of these cases were
from before his prison sentence but right
now you are illegally accessing Mr Lynn's
account so any evidence that I received from that
gets tossed in court this is why Batman exists
job is to find your mom and build
a prosecutable case if there's a
crime I don't know she's unpacked way
more information than you have yeah
also a Javi is still on the run thank God
she moved it down to eight bucks an hour
uh yeah she works here and you haven't heard from
her at all nope I've tried calling dming her I've
been stopped covering her shift for the last
two weeks well wow wow she's special do you mind
calling if you hear from her what does that mean
is she special what this movie's bananas oh my God
I thought he turned his location off not till they
got to Colombia seeing her oh frequently visited
two what
oh that's his murder house I'm calling about Kevin
Lynn he he visited your house like two weeks ago
June 8th what was he doing there what it's a
re-entry entry oh and did he ever mention my mom
slice her up I got the receipt
wait you got it what did he buy
just this oh God this is not good wait what
was he doing to this woman before exactly
was he just scamming them because I don't
know he went to the prison for three years
something weird with your mom being in there
saying some stuff that you don't want to see
oh it's his though oh but yeah you would see he's
probably gonna miss it doesn't matter either way
oh God oh God uh Kevin here and I thought I'd
just try to get things started what's your
favorite 80s band okay another video you seem
great and I'd love to know more about you I
certainly admire your persistence so what
would you like to know what's your favorite
80s he asked you yes there we go follow
up New Edition okay he totally stole my
answer huh I I tried to leave a voicemail her
voicemail is full when I look at her I just
I just see her father and it's like we've
we've really been through a lot together oh
I don't think that I could forgive myself
if anything ever happens to her you know
you've seen like a really great mom one day
she'll get that wow this shit's so hypnotic
okay here we go about her past
I have a record I really like you and I I just
didn't want I didn't want to screw this up but
if you you don't want to keep talking I totally
get it oh poor guy I think everything's all right
yeah I do something in her past followed
her to Colombia maybe so far away though
that thing with the this movie oh it's
a Love Lock yeah oh oh my God oh my God
oh the live cameras Oh but can you go
back oh you can't Javi can you wait for me
oh yeah okay let me check the archive you can
go back huh cool there did you see them yeah
he has a lock and he pushes her off the bridge
proposing what is he doing what's this red
thing here we go here we go or
maybe he's gonna oh God propose
oh my God does she say yes she said yes no I know
they were at the bridge you were
right he wasn't trying to con her
oh my God no no
oh my God [__] [__] that's scary no I hate
it I hate it so much holy [__] who are these
people oh my God this is warning from an anonymous
source we're mobilizing units across the city as
we speak oh my God so what now is there anything
I can do the best thing you can do to help
to help we'll be in touch oh my god look up
that license plate look at something about
money but what if these people hurt her they have
no reason to either I've already go find them off
yeah come on any white van blow it up
oh my gosh any and all my son Carlos lost
his mom in the trouble gets worse and one
day we had this big fight and he said I
didn't even wanted to talk to me again it
doesn't change a pattern slow have you tried
reaching out he knows what I am is he still
charging her for this this is a 48-hour
event here he's a long-term Ninja okay
she's drinking she doesn't drink
mocktails oh mock mock tails what
oh that's not wine in the pic well
she could drink a lot of different
things is that not her hand and she
was stolen way before I'm confused
oh my God she helped like steal her
and be her standing I don't know but
that's bunny cake hand right and then
maybe he posted like but then no why
would he send it I'm conf I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't know
her and the photos yeah oh my God
because they disappeared along
she's the stand-in I was right
right oh my God that is terrifying
oh my God the live view is gonna show
the bunny cake oh my God it's bunny cake
ah it's bunny cake holy [__] I
can't believe this has happened my God
why would you not think this through you dumbass
so he's not a good guy so he's part of the
oh my God yeah these cells are off Grace
Allen was in fact impersonated in an alleged
scheme by the suspects behind me of Miss Allen
we now believe never left Los Angeles yeah
oh my God that's why he was saying you're
literally perfect seemingly swapped out
why would he put up because I hide his to hide the
fact that she he killed that he so the kidnapping
was all just fake for the camera take the 405 and
then a totally different woman gets out at LAX
Kevin did something to her that's when it happened
okay he only ever stopped for three minutes along
the way he must have had help for the Uber driver
the one person who knows for sure what's going
on here is Mr Lynn yeah we find him and we find
Grace Allen oh man call that guy back from Nevada
they say that the police told us some local
students that lean hired to be part of a movie
oh my God oh he paid them to capture them like
a moo oh my God he said it was a reality show
oh my like a lifestyle travel thing all shot
on the iPhone and stuff oh my God your mom was
already gone Miss Paige never saw her
did she get a good look at the driver
she couldn't see his face from
back seat yo Kevin for sure
you mentioned that you don't have any extended
family right the best of your knowledge your
mom has never gone by any of their names no
the past all right turns out Grace Allen is
just one of the mystery woman's aliases whose real
identity lies locked behind a court-ordered seal
what what the [__] is happening tried
leaving a voicemail but I'm writing a
joke it's Angel just checking in on things
with your mom also did you find my watch
[Laughter] zero known family members
other than the daughter that's Palace
us this is crazy it's just the
internet too no no it's not just
the internet it's the police too
hey don't let them put you down
Monday Wednesday and Friday it looks
just like this but even you said
you said right she knew about Kevin
the whole time it's not a show this
is my mom obviously you should just go now
we're gonna find out her dad's still alive
let's move his ability to put you in the POV is
very impressive yeah you're like with them surging
you don't want to Google this
[__] it'll come back to haunt you
this is nordvpn I'll delete how to hide internet
oh oh oh download that [__] right away girl
we need to get there because I need to know
10 hours ago my God
they're talking to each other
no are you you uh wait along
are you home he's gonna be like no I'm in Colombia
no maybe it's not the mob
the lawyer they're on to it
[Music] uh maybe he logged back in oh
there's Heather yeah holy [__]
I knew it right when she was like
I'm not coming over right away
girl you ain't a good friend uh
Dave she is solving so much of this
on her own I have to record her
onto the watch now I need you to stay on the
phone while I'm in there in case something happens
because someone is a parent it doesn't mean
they do not make mistakes I guess you wouldn't
oh that's a cool
yo this shit's wild this is what I can
do my heartbeat is 96 so is mine yeah
girl you're doing good good
goodness crazy
oh my God what what's going on why
is it a horror movie so dark and
what's happening is she fallen over
behind the desk like she's dead now
[Music] okay erasing local discs
money and run away together
talk she dies who dies being held against
her will she's being forced into this
oh yeah that's her necklace oh my God is Heather
dead is she in the other room is she she's in that
dark Road she's totally dead she's in that room
she's beaten up or something something weird oh
my God yeah she half the life where where
oh my god oh yeah oh yep wow it this movie
did she get her killed
but I told her then yeah look Mr Lin
is the key to all of this police may
have spotted him near the border he
is our best chance in finding your mom
wow dang the dead dad is orchestrating
all this from down below six feet so crazy
what if she's she's being
watched the whole yeah time
looks like it cyberghost VPN yeah I
mean he set up her computer remember
is this still Heather messaging
or the freaking Mom it's I think
it's the mom I think it's the mom okay oh my God
you know oh my God holy junk don't
shoot him you gotta detain him
[Applause]
what what just happened
don't shoot flee with money stolen from
missing woman oh girl did you clear your
voicemail maybe she's been trying to
oh she's gonna check all the voicemails
oh this is going to be sad oh my God 99 girl
I feel like she's a suspect though I don't
know I don't know what to believe God me neither
that's what I'm saying maybe if you called her hey
what hey Junebug it's
you just had the password wrong
right you didn't add the ug
that was the first guest that we
when we earlier in the movie yeah oh
oh someone been trying to hunt your mom down
uh what's happening
the guy who lied about the Nevada girls
the Nevada guy in the murder house
wait what
oh my God what how what does
this mean it's the same place
oh
my God he's killed your dad and now
he she oh my God this is Jimmy from
the from the church thing there's
a line to explain I didn't mean to
scare you to tell you what's going on
right now before I call the police holy
holy this was not your this is a fake
person this is you were stolen as a child
and none of this is real she's not your real mom
what our jokes came true there are things
that you need to know like what like oh my
God you're a dirty liar and you weren't
my father and you faked a nosebleed how
I don't want to sit here anymore me neither
oh my God I want to roam girl you better get
a knife out of the kitchen and be like you
can talk to me through the freaking window
you deserve to know what happened
we all do yeah come on get to it
oh my God you opened the door he could be
crazy who's literally in Zach who's crazy
her real name is
we're always fighting
I've been searching for you ever since
so you scheme to get rid of her like what
she lied to a judge to have me put in
prison so that she could have you to herself
she lied to me oh and then him and Kevin
okay we're in eastern prison in Texas
why did they scheme together to get rid
of mom then she scared him in prison
yeah oh my God driver you know
where Mom is you dirty liar
we need to hit a punching bag
oh my god oh where is Irish
oh you got a fake like you don't know
oh my God fake like you don't know you get
it [Music] [__] oh my God sounds
like she hid you away for good reason
what's that James it's just the altitude that
is fine Daddy's just been doing a lot of cocaine
no big deal my own daughter now she said I
saw you go out back uh he's gonna like me um
it is frustrating trying to reason with you
when you won't acknowledge Baseline facts
less than a year then how do you explain
what I found in the hallway closet so you
need to cut the [__] and tell me what you
did with it holy junk I swear to God I will
find you and you will die in a pool of your own
blood before you take it from me do you hear me
oh my God I'm surprised she was
able to hide this information for
so long yeah like how did she say
hidden for 12 years from this guy
oh I can I'm not law and oh she
helped hide like helped her stay
hidden even from June like June was
never able to find this information
safe at home okay [Music] oh that's why we saw
in the beginning she deleted everything okay
got it I can't imagine what you must be
going through we really hate to see you
go I really had no idea oh that was
her okay clever clever [__] movie
lie holy you're one thing and then we'll leave
wow prison reform did nothing she is in
there oh dang girl you almost out of there
you have a tool to use yeah you better knock him
in the head so hard that he does not come back up
[Music]
yes yes yes hit him again oh my God
oh [__]
no time for sorry get in the car oh my
God move I can't I really can't get in
the freaking car he killed Heather he's
crazy he thinks he's punishing me for
what I did to him I'm gonna tell
you everything I want you to take
the holy oh my God what is he in
um felt like a hole that very hurt welcome
to the cemetery I talked about earlier
oh my God hello hello hello can anyone hear me
okay where's your phone it's at the
house if only I I could just just
oh call your computer call your phone do you
remember the address to this place oh everything
needs to be paired with a phone oh God oh God wait
what unless Harvey yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I found my mom I need your help okay I need
you to go to the first picture on my Instagram
I see great on the house behind us there are no
five four one okay call the police
and tell them we are at four
I don't know oh javi's gotta have filled in the
blank now I need you to come with me right now
James back off leave her alone one more word
from you and you are dead ask again oh my god
oh I don't believe it holy oh my God [Music] oh
my God take that glass oh my God shove it in his
throat oh my God kill him oh my God please come
on come on come on you can do a tune kill him
um that's okay I'm just making this Carter
[Music] yes
please come on June finish the job
the gun's in there I'm dying
anyone and anyone can hear me
oh he fell over he died
oh this is such [__] if she died she's gonna
die this is such [__] I promise if we could
I'll start checking my boys videos
hey Siri
[Music]
call 9-1-1 yes what what this
[__] is awesome God this is wild
oh my goodness oh just a movie oh this is the
dramatic reenactment they
made a Netflix movie yeah
foreign
[Music]
listen I just wanted to remind you that your bus
leaves at 8 35 in the morning so you might want
to set multiple alarms yep oh guess what I got
a new boyfriend Javi unfriended me on Facebook
oh at the beginning of the movie she said
the sacrifices I've made for you oh yeah
it just sounded like typical pear and stuff
but no no love you there you go girl just just
hit the like button that's what I was gonna
say nice call back hit that like button Bobo
yes that's great hahaha
she'll never forget [Music]
oh my God that made me like tear up at the end
yeah a little American Nick Johnson all right
man my God that was crazy that was that was crazy
insane I did not really want to watch this movie
before it's terrible attest I was not leaning
towards it and we decided it wasn't and that
turned into one of the most memorable experiences
I like all God the twist and turns
it did not stop it didn't stop
this was insane it was like an anxiety attack
I mean every five minutes it it kept it kept
dangling in this this like um I don't know what
the terminology is what is the term I'm looking
for a piece of like string cheese in front of
you to go and have we crossed into the realm of
unbelievability yet is this too much for you like
the entire time but it just kept reeling you back
in and explaining it away and you're like yeah
yeah this is nuts but I like it this is wild
wild Wackadoo wild it was only all that I was like
isn't there a window there has to be a window in
that room and also knock down that freaking door
to get your mom out right like kick it down but
I'm okay with that that's fine everything else
before holy junk I mean just with them showing
you the lock like in the beginning we're like
me locked her up in a basement it was like I'm
totally on board did he Gilder and like all that
stuff and holy holy junk just and then but they
have they have you going though like when at first
you're like oh this Kevin guy is awful yeah he's
bad and then they you go through the history and
you're like ah maybe he actually is all right yeah
actually oh we never buy it like this movie just
knew how to play it every time there was a Twist
that happened there would be another twist that
happened another one where you it's a really good
mystery thriller that is really that is insane I
wonder if this is preferred over the predecessor
um I mean I'm gonna tell you right now now I will
never forget this movie right now I don't remember
a lot about the a little bit but not a lot that
is just an insane story and I I loved it I love
it okay but the one thing that was not explained
is how Kevin died right didn't he reach I know
but but we were like come on man he was like that
and then I'm like it's yeah I would have I kind
of want to know but I'm like it doesn't really
matter like honestly this was a wackadoo wild
ride but like what did he do why did they shoot
him yeah maybe he reached for something I don't
know it's the stock I think this style is so smart
because it is so much of just like going through
like these screens and stuff because it the the
problem that I have with most like found is it's
not exactly found footage but it is that I would
if there's a category to put it in I would say
found footage is there is there like a terminology
that I don't know that you guys can explain to
me because if it was just pure found footage like
someone who just doesn't stop recording then what
we get even it would be actually even harder
to believe but to do this kind of like hyper
style editing whether it's like a bunch of screen
monitoring screen recording and with like actually
some cinematic music inter spliced into here with
some wild editing actually makes this quality feel
more believable because I'm never getting pulled
out going why is this still recording that's
ridiculous you know because that's the problem
with most of these found footage things is like
why would they still be recording but to be doing
like this almost surveillance type of quality
I thought was excellent uh yeah yeah because
it keeps you in real time in in her searching
leaving notes yeah calling the other people we're
in real time with them while also going through
found footage also the the happenstance with
the security cameras is also was dope yeah I
think it was fun it's so fun because it starts off
where or is this going to be just some like really
sad drama Thriller yeah which it just starts going
Congo I had I was not prepared first oh my God
this is just gonna escalatingly get weird when
we found out it was bad bunny what was her name
bunny girl yeah oh my freaking like what it's so
well thought out so well thought out like you got
to think about so much when you're crafting one
of these things together they thought it through
like timelessly like I'm so fascinated with how
the execution went down yeah I'm wondering I
had a storyboard for every shot first to be like
because no one in the editing room is going to be
like what a fine if we're seeing a computer screen
but it's like I wonder if they hadn't ever all of
it storyboarded out so that you would see that the
frame included in her shot of face a video of her
plus her Windows plus her face time with the thing
back here right so it's like you have that's just
it's nuts well not just not just with the way it's
shot and edited how much you got to think that out
but the writing oh yeah I don't even want to know
I mean that's why two people wrote it and directed
it because it's so much where do you start with
this yeah where do you even begin and you're
like well I have this idea for this person missing
but we got to come up with kind of a mystery plot
around it like how do you flush the stick out
where where was the nebulous for how how this
all came to be for it's 45 episodes of Unsolved
Mystery yeah people do it I mean I I've seen a lot
of those like True Crime doc series and and people
go through like extreme lands like there's a crazy
[__] that goes down yeah things that sound like
so absurd but really happen in real life uh so uh
this doesn't this didn't cross too far if it was
if it was like the dad was actually presumed dead
and he was still alive this whole time that right
then I'd be like okay too much but but then but
they fed it to us with the nosebleed yeah yeah
that's how that you picked up on the drug habit
right like when you when you went back because
yeah because at the beginning you're thinking
brain aneurysm yeah like oh the moment [Music]
it is so well crafted I'm just so impressed by
how how much they thought this story through from
beginning to end and and and like for every twist
for every every curveball they throw you
right down to the woman uh where you're
like hired actors then they explain
it and you're like oh [__] yeah
first payment but not the second one everything
is thought out yeah for every twist there was a
turn every detail is thought out and storm
rate do you remember her from The Last of
Us episode uh when and the one in the mall I
yeah that was her yeah yeah at the beginning
okay if you're on YouTube there's this whole
thing about on our patreon intro where I was
trying to tell you that's who it was and then we
ended up just talking about Stormy Daniels yeah
all different things he interrupted me yeah
you're like oh is it this person and then I
never told you who it was that's who it was she's
phenomenal in this room great phenomena held this
movie Down dang girl yeah amazing and they even
made the relationship uh really believable with
how it forms with the Javi oh yeah I I I'm like
oh of course he has a sentiment because he lost
his not lost his son but didn't have contact
and she's the same age so he would of course
be that guy who's willing to help out a very
young girl try to find her mom yeah like of
course he would be like you don't even have to
pay me my eight dollars and also probably still
answer her calls yeah because they formed
and it was not unbelievable that they had
only talked twice and that you know he he even
said I hope your money hasn't gone to waste so
I'm wondering she obviously was able to pay him
something which is why he was able to follow up
go to the Love Lock thing then after that it just
became a genuine relationship uh especially when
she found the footage right yeah because then
the footage made it oh Javi now sees mom was
kidnapped because she probably was like look
look here they were the love luck white van
yeah and then he's like oh this is not made up
he's in it now and he I mean of course like how
would you not want to see it through and or
be there for her when she calls right like
after I've just kind of I've started I'm sorry
so mindful about what we just witnessed that was
such a crazy ride so good it was a roller coaster
in somehow the the writers thought if we added in
for her for him to just go what happened to
your father we didn't read into that that
wasn't even Exposition in my brain at all
for Javi to go what happened to your father
we're all kind of thinking that a little bit
but not really then and then they also bring
up somehow in that conversation it's like two
minutes where they get a heart to heart so now
we actually have formed a relationship with Javi
when for me as a writer I'd be like we're running
out of time it's not going to seem realistic for
Javi and her to talk about his son who's gone
and he never talked to a son before how do we add
that in I believed it that it came out genuinely
I didn't feel that that plot line was forced and
that's what comes through that's a nice callback
at the end right because she says you should talk
to your son yeah the way they tether every there's
like there's so many different kinds of callbacks
right down to the whole Siri Motif at the this is
a great advertisement for Apple uh yeah right
down to the to the Siri Motif at the very end
Nicole into it like they get you really even if
you're not like tech savvy they get I feel like
it gets you really because they were doing things
like I didn't know you could do that but it gets
you acquainted with essentially the rules of the
tech so well that you can buy into a lot of things
if there's like a nitpick that maybe I would have
in this movie and it's but I was so pulled in that
I wasn't even really thinking about it was just
how fast she can like search for stuff yes like
things just go chips even when they're like fake
calling to pretending to be Kevin like there's no
way you look like I've tried cheating on [__]
before right like I'm doing a quiz at a bar you
can't do that you can't move that fast it's not
that fast yeah what is this 7g yeah it's insane
ridiculous but other than that you're so wrapped
into the immediacy of the of the anxiety of the
situation at all times that you're not even
thinking about some of these things that are
a little bit too far-fetched because there's no
mistake in it the problem that happens with like
found footage is that they try to make a lot of
times I try to make it so real that you get pulled
out when something's obviously not real this movie
he knows to ride the line between we're definitely
doing cinema right now like this is a movie yeah
that is in the guise of a found footage you know
what I mean yeah and I think they did such an
excellent job at that uh on all fronts and they
managed to have like a great character narrative
uh throughout the dad being like totally unhinged
at the end and going full bomb villain that
might have been a little I I felt like there
was like zero Nuance to that by the end like he
was just so like villainous by the end yeah like
why is he gonna like tie up his daughter and make
it he's already now bad to her at that point when
he was tying her up I'm like how are you gonna you
can't explain this yourself like you're you're now
you've locked her in her room with her mom and you
shot her mom so like where do we go from here with
him like what's his thought process which I didn't
I didn't understand that but also remember how
they were like money went somewhere so the money
went to Kevin right and then Kevin and maybe the
dad they just shared it so I guess the plan was
to steal all the money the money come out and run
away with the daughter yeah I'm just like dad you
can't come back from that daughter's not she's not
she does not like you like this is an ultimate
this was just as massive massive Revenge plan
right to be like you're gonna hurt as much as
I did you took my daughter away now I take your
daughter away from you maybe he wasn't planning
to kill mom he just that's why he shot her in the
what was the pro I mean I I would feel like the
LAPD would stay with June the whole time yeah like
why are they like here a buy 13 14 year old one
in the morning and we're gonna go now for sure so
like this is the time when the Killer goes yeah
you know yeah that I mean she she is she is 18.
that's the same time I still feel like it's like
what is this like specific time shift that they
have to stick around like just no bad guys showing
up tonight we're gonna we're gonna take off now
little nitpicks like that but other than that the
movie is dazzlingly impressive because because
they have thought through every single through
line and and like so many different plot holes
like this movie I I we're probably like a couple
of we're raising a couple of questions is what
we're doing not not even sure but if it's a
nitpick a lot of it is like questions the but
this movie thought about so much that could have
been just big ass plot holes and and leaps into
suspension of disbelief like they thought of so
many different things and and literally like every
10 minutes whenever they presented something that
could have been too much they managed to answer
the question they managed to explain it without a
lot of exposition like we didn't know where hair
where which side Heather was on we thought she
was messaging me like she's in on it and then
she goes to find her and the only way that we
really knew besides yes the guy says it later
but we knew because the picture said if you talk
she dies yeah and that was our only information
that we got that Heather is like oh she was being
set up and and then skipped to the guy kind of
explaining it that yeah she was she she wasn't
in on it and now we gotta go to the next person
yeah his great propulsive music it was a
great mystery a little fantastic acting yeah
um and uh just just an immense amount of
emotions it was a very emotional too yeah
it's very emotional with great character resolved
by the end and a lot of great misleads throughout
if the missing people see this who are the
two people I called their names out at the end
because I was like I should remember their names
now listen will Merrick and John something send
me a t-shirt you know what I mean where's the
missing merchandise and now I need some merch
okay I need it in my life uh writers and directors
can make that happen I know you got a box in your
house that you didn't give to all of the crew
so over here you know what it also did so well
is in the beginning the first half before it
gets all twist and turny right you know before
it get because there's there is there's a lot
I thought you said turdy yeah because because
there's a lot there is a lot of like very specific
visuals that take some adjusting like especially
I don't know if this is the way the movie
searching operates but for me on my first
go around like this is kind of an adjustment
of a visual experience that I was having at
the very beginning uh it was like a little bit
over stimulating and yeah at the same time though
as every like what was the first big twit the
Kevin guy right whenever what his past is and
things having an affair and stuff yes before it
gets there the way they handled everything was
extremely relatable you know yeah like the choices
she was making how she was going about the choices
the interactions that she was having they made so
many things of like this is how a lot of us would
go about in the operation of this and thinking it
through and and and even like certain apps that
were being used and how to handle it like I was it
was so so impressed with how relatable it was feel
right down to the even the taskrabbit of having to
lower the price reduction and everything like that
right they made so many relatable choices for
everyone to connect to that way when it starts
getting a little bit more heightened and and and
uh I don't want to say ridiculous but just hide it
yeah you're still on board because they've already
got you so connected to the realistic the reality
yeah they grounded it really well with an anchor
in the beginning so as you go through you're like
you weren't thrown out at the top to go this is
unbelievable you're like no this is believable
like yeah um that was frantic and exciting
I I loved it I was great and it was a real
mindfulness really it really was it just didn't
stop it was like scary in all the right ways every
single way guys Bravo what did you think about
this movie visic leave your thoughts down below
um I hope this movie gets more
attention I'm only see it's got
a thousand thousand people voted on
Rotten Tomatoes that's it come on
she deserves it and uh we'll see you guys soon
thanks for being here Maria Maria Hammond my dear
so she got me this uh Doctor Strange Cape that
you might have seen me wearing a couple of videos
before and then I just opened a package that we
got from her which had this really lovely letter
and here's a photo of me rocking this cable
and I was walking around WonderCon this year
and then there was a special present in this box
that I just took out and she didn't say she wanted
an unboxing video so I was like all right well
let me just take a look at it then and I wish
I did an unboxing video because she got me the eye
of agamoto it is they're gonna be right here we're
gonna put it in the background and oh my God
it is so cool it is so wickedly cool I I legit
love this so much I was so surprised to see it um
we're gonna be doing another live stream and I'm
definitely gonna be wearing this the entire time
because wowza look at that oh my God wait wait
wait oh I think you see the eye yeah yeah I just
there's the eye there's the eye of agamoto right
there thank you so much Maria you know this movie
deals with someone um in search of their mother
and I've said it several times if there's anyone
who would be like the mother at our patreon page
it would be you thank you for constantly spoiling
us and for being such a such a a nurturing Soul
at every corner and yeah I just love the hell out
of you so I just want to keep this simple and keep
it short of course thank you for this awesome
gift but mainly thank you so much for being you
this is really this is really freaking sweet and I
love the hell out of you my dear thank you [Music]